Logan's may have been public but we all
know that there are many men with wives
out there that have crazy paths that
people don't know about and you know I I
I was thinking about this the other day
and I was thinking about how men have so
much to lose in marriage like they have
everything to lose and these days
there's really not much to gain you know
we saw in the last video that there's a
50 divorce rate and if we assume half of
the men are unhappy in marriage you know
of them that stay married right and I
think that's a honestly a generous
number if I'm gonna be honest
um or they stay together for the kids or
whatever
it's really a 75 failure rate